The cringe levels are off the charts. It's like staring into the eclipse. Okay.
I couldn't lie to you. It takes a lot to get through,
but when you summit this mountain,
you will never be the same ladies and gentlemen,
if you can get through not one but two poems about education,
let me say you have transcended human potential.
You've gone beyond monk-like discipline.
You've achieved the level of enlightenment that the Dalai Lama can only dream
of. So please leave a comment below. If you finish this whole episode,
I expect many of you will not be able to you'll have to tap out.
But if you'd like to see moments like this,
you can go subscribe to our podcast channel quick context for the video.
So it's not immediately disorienting. We have a call in show.
Sometimes this was one of our viewers who called in and all of a sudden he
mentioned that he had a bunch of poems on education.
And of course we had to hear them. I think poetry.
And there's some pretty good job prospects there. It will give us the poetry.
I have one called education, frustration. Hang on here. Here. Let me, let me, I,
I have it out right now. Okay? Okay. Okay. I'm ready here.
My school thinks that I'm a fool. It piles on rule after rule.
At some point it was so boring. It made people drool. So uncool.
They just told me to believe, but not to proceed.
Never told me how to deal with the application infestation or the interview.
Crap Stu I got good grades and it seems like I did my best in school
for decades.
They never prepared me for the treacherous fonts that I had to deal with in
my job hunt. If I could go back,
I tell some of these teachers and professors to dismiss the boring, useless,
and unhelpful, quiet and tell them,
tell them to shove their worthless assignments up their homework
projects, tests bugging me like household pests.
A good job right out of college.
Surely they jets craft behind the school Gates and stuck behind a desk and a
charade. So grotesque.
Now that's the very definition of Kafka S learning cursive, cursive,
algebra, and Shakespeare. I'm no alcoholic,
but it made me want a beer diploma on a well, a piece of paper,
wild they're empty promises go up and vapor standardized tests are
one size fits. None.
Students left behind from the lies that the system spun making us buy a
cap and a gown.
While student debt makes us drought that makes me want to rap,
but frown and achieve China manufactured,
honors medallion not fit for me.
The leader of the revolutionary battalion from now on,
I will do my best to get the ultimate test and become the best
ex exposing these schooling frauds in front of the eyes of God will
build a foundation and rise to the occasion.
I'll go out and spread the world about these deceitful turds,
making an inspiration for the entire nation.
Instead of just sitting at home on my PlayStation a master's degree.
Well, I'm the master of me, King of my own destiny,
calling out chumps who waste our youth future. So careless to me,
Dr. B the real doctor of philosophy saying enough with this pretentious
Sophos street. I'm a post-grad from the school of life,
cutting through the with my truthiness night, Republicans, Democrats,
and all those other corrupt fat cats. They use. We,
the people as their personal doormats, the whole education scam is nothing.
Before you flam the policies of RD.
Dunkin donuts are enough to make you want to go nuts in schools, healthcare,
failing out there, prevailing, pushing the school system over the railing.
So come with me and join my movement.
We'll give society so much needed improvement.
[Inaudible] that was the cringy best thing I've ever heard in my life.
But it also was very impressive. Was that great. Eight was that bad.
And I have a second one. This, this one is more a job market related.
Yeah, Arnie Duncan was the secretary of education,
but he's been flunking real life skills and job training for those. He says, no.
What a stupid rainless, Shakespeare, algebra, and other useless crap.
Well, that's how you end up in a worthless degree.
Tech trap and there's ITT tech ended up in a wreck and the for-profit
schools, milking money from students.
They see as fool creating a generation of debtors. Isn't cool.
Promising a decent paying job out of college. Seriously, do these idiot.
I've no knowledge. I see a PhD in philosophy,
serving coffee at Starbucks.
While these babies school couldn't give less of a.
They send her resume on Craigslist, no responses. It's making me.
Then they call back and it's time to cue the laugh track of description
administrative low.
It makes my stomach churn show up for an interview.
Dress up in your suit and tie hoping you don't get an.
Interviewer who makes you want to cry? First thing the guy says is,
Oh boy, do you agree? How nice? What about skills? And I say,
hold up skills. Well, I can graph X. And Y does that fit the bill?
He laughs in my face, proving the education systems in disgrace.
What's the job description I inquire. He says,
kissing my all day and catering to my every desire is this,
all this Turk and say,
I tell him what you better get your head out of your butt and the poop out of
your ears. No way are you, Oh,
this isn't what I've been preparing for all
my money. By making you look funny,
I don't accept your job because I've got spunk and your BS makes you stink like
a skunk. The only place you belong is in the gum. My Opus morons,
who don't think I know how to get a simple job done. Well, it's a good thing.
I'm at the poetry lounge. We know how to have fun.
So short haul, cruise blogging, port.
Schools and job market are failing,
but I'm still prevailing using my comedy to push the whole corrupt system over
the railing. So join me and let's make the movement. It's about time.
We petition these people to make something.
Wow.